we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
sort of interesting question that came
in take a listen to this
hey david two questions in two quick
comments I wanted to ask who is your
least favorite mainstream media
personality and who do you think does
the most damage and as far as I comments
go P know if they were referring to Fox
News is state-run media but I'm
wondering it actually makes more sense
to think of it the other way around
given that I'll get a list of his policy
ideas from Fox News we actually have a
media run State and then I just want to
say I think that Michael Cohen seems
like a really really dumb version
install Goodman it's like a sleazy
lawyer kind of guy okay so a lot in
there so let me address the last part
yeah there is something in Michael Cohen
that is reminiscent of Saul Goodman the
character from Breaking Bad and from
better call Saul I don't think you're
wrong about that okay now as far as
let's work backwards because I'm leading
up to the toughest question I think it
is more accurate to say that we have a
media run State Fox is controlling so
much of what the President of the United
States focuses on thinks about and works
on because he watches that show and it's
just abundantly clear so I don't think
Fox's state-run media I think that we
have a media run-run state that is a
very very good point who do I think is
the worst corporate media personality
you know it's I don't remember all of
them offhand but I think that that judge
Jeanine Pirro is absolutely one of the
worst and I've talked about her before
and I know you know Hannity has a bigger
reach and and he says horrible things
and the Fox and Friends people are doing
major damage because Trump watches them
but there's something about judge
Jeanine Pirro that to me makes her one
of the most vile corporate media people
out there but it's close I mean that
there's probably a dozen people Brian
Kilmeade is absolutely and totally
horrible that Trump guy I don't know if
he's Jeffrey Lord I don't even know if
he's still on CNN but he was on there
all the time in the lead-up to the
election absolutely vile and depraved
guy I don't know there's a long list but
Jeanine Pirro is certainly near the top
of the list for me we've got a great
bonus show for you today we will talk
about a new Court decision that says
women cannot have prior salaries used
against them for future job negotiations
a report says that under a thousand
people attended a game between the Rays
and White Sox at guaranteed rate field
interesting name and we will also talk
about a transgender Runner ruling that
relates to the upcoming Boston Marathon
so a lot of interesting stories
including some local Boston stories and
I will also tell you what's been going
on here in Las Vegas Nevada
get the bonus show by becoming a member
at david pakman.com slash membership and
or by becoming a patron for at least
five bucks a month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show I will speak to you on
the bonus show